this week in our school matter series we
are looking at mental and physical
health issues in schools and today we
are focusing on kids sports and an
organization that works to remove the
barriers that prevent children from
participating only about 20% of students
between ages 6 and 19 meet recommended
guidelines for physical activity and
just 37% of 6 to 12 year olds play a
team sport regularly that is despite
studies showing the social mental and
physical benefits of athletics Jesse
Palmer was an NFL quarterback for five
seasons and is the national spokesman
for good sports the organization
encourages and help kids get involved in
athletics Jesse good morning government
so happy great to have you here as
someone who grew up playing sports
encouraging my kids to do it there is a
lot of research out there what is it
about the benefits that we get from our
kids playing sports obviously has played
a huge influence and factored in my life
but I think as a kid when I look back it
really helped me develop life skills
socializing there's the obvious benefits
that we know about physical health I
think also emotional well-being -
there's a lot of valuable life lessons
that we learn whether it's team work
together nough sportsmanship these sorts
of things I also felt as a young kid
playing sports growing up and I played a
lot of different types of sports when I
was getting physical activity I was able
to focus more in the classroom I believe
I got better grades as a young kid
because I was more active because I was
playing sporting it didn't detract from
your studies I would think of being a
giant it would be a detraction and
distraction for you it's certainly not
especially when I was at the elementary
school able to write because it's recess
and physical education P and those core
curriculums which we're now seeing a lot
of schools across this country losing
those curriculums and it's unfortunate
for a lot of children that want to play
sport you mentioned that you played a
lot of sports and you think it's
important that kids play more than one
sport and I think kids should play as
many different types of sports as they
can whether it be team sports and
individual sports because I think you
learn a lot of different lessons we
talked about team sports and
togetherness teamwork but I think
individual sports teach you about
self-reliance self motivation how you
can handle the spotlight I think there's
a lot of different lessons you learn
from a lot of different types of sports
for kids that can afford to play if that
are lucky enough like I was as a young
kid what we're seeing today a
socio-economic divide between
families who can afford to send their
kids to play sports or just schools that
have curriculum can be it is expensive
Jessie what do you say about people that
aren't good in sports I have very vivid
memories in elementary school when used
to choose teams yes and I was one of the
last people and they say we had Gayle
last time now it's your turn
Wayne said that to me Wayne Wayne I
won't say his last name in case he's
still alive but it's a type of you find
it but it's a type of thing that when
you hear that it's soka and I wasn't
good in sports I actually wasn't so I
understood it but it's still very
painful so what do you say about the
kids that aren't very good I think it's
really important he'll do it
he teachers parents and I think coaches
around the country really have to help
kids and encourage kids to just want to
participate and be in the game I totally
understand I was this way too as a young
kid with Python I was afraid of failure
I didn't like to lose and I would like
to be picked last there were some sports
where I got picked last two at the
playground and I didn't like that either
but I really think it's important that
these teachers these coaches and these
parents are encouraging their kids to
just participate being the game because
it's about them having fun but Jesse you
raised the question what the the
socio-economic divide that really is an
issue just a third of kids from families
earning less than $25,000 a year's play
a teen sport the gear is expensive
the average score I put the average cost
up there six hundred can be six hundred
and seventy bucks and what we're and
what we're seeing is this divide where
families that can't afford sports their
children are getting more active and
playing more sports and yet families who
can't afford it are playing less and
less so that divide is a widening in
this group I work with good sports
they've done a phenomenal job
identifying schools and programs around
the country that are in need of apparel
they need Footwear they need equipment
and they've donated forty three million
dollars since 2003 that has positively
impacted 7 million children in all 50
states whatever that's a very very big
thing playing sports incredibly
important the risk of injury do we have
enough trained coaches athletic
directors that understand the risks of
injury it's always going to be a factor
and certainly injuries are a part of
sports and certain sports - I know a
football that's become a big topic
recently the more we're learning about
brain trauma CTE
that's become a hot topic and there are
quote/unquote collision sports so that's
a big thing your apps
right the quality of equipment and also
the quality of coaching I think goes a
long long way and protecting our kids
all right Jesse always good to see you I
have a question that has nothing to do
with sports because a lot of people know
you from yeah so I noticed you're not
wearing a wedding ring does this mean
you're available
would you like to how much time do we
left in this segments also it was very
quickly we have a couple second I have
met someone who is way out of my league
who I'm very very in love with oh not
married yet I'm just fooling her every
day
that's what's her name her name's Emily
Emily she's at home watching she told me
she'd be watching all right Thank You
Emily listen guys in the green room and
the green room Jesse took a selfie with
Oprah and said this is gonna be the
highlight of my day I go well you
haven't set with me we'll take a second
all day for this commercial well take
second place Thank You Jesse much rather
glad I see you here